keep your hands up on top of your head
[Music]
man
we'll wait till another unit gets
here just go ahead and just keep facing
that direction for us all
right
196 got three subjects here all three St
Wai for addition
un keep your hands up on top of your
head
man
on top of your head
man dude you got to listen and keep your
hands on top of your head all
right the guy in the black shirt's not
being 100% Cooperative he was refusing
to keep
us all
right male subject in the black shirt I
want you to walk backwards to the sound
of my
voice walk backwards on the sidewalk to
the sound of my
voice just the guy in the black
shirt keep coming back walk
back don't look back here look straight
ahead you got commands stop turn to your
left turn to your left we got to get
back farther over here
all right walk straight back straight
back keep coming keep coming don't look
back here stop stop get down on your
knees down on your knees put your hands
straight back behind
you
you grab my phone we'll grab it in a
second
would we tell you to keep your hands on
top of your head you need to C your
hand it's pretty
obvious
I
got I got what did you put me in the car
take a seat what did you put me in the
car have a seat bro damn BR is clean
yall doing this
weird
put your hands on top of your head
man just do it we're to have you come
back towards us keep them up on top of
your head
man
subject in the y in the white
shirt face away from us walk back to the
sound of my
voice walk back to the sound of my
voice sir in the red I need you to face
forward for me okay just keep facing
forward we'll explain everything in a
minute put your hands on top of your
head for
stop get down on your
knees put your arm straight back behind
you put your hands on your
head
do
ad
not saying that at all man huh not
saying that at
all my partner explained it to you
somebody called
and
all right
back you ready sir in the red go ahead
and step back towards my location just
keep walking backwards like that all
right just follow my voice doing good
just keep walking right on back all
right we explain everything back
here go ahead and stop right there just
h no keep your hands on top of your head
for me bud all right just drop down on
your knees for me okay all right take
your arms straight back behind you all
right
all right all right man what's going on
is someone called and said that a uh
black me whole subject about 13 wearing
red walking with a black male with a
black shirt had a gun in his hand okay
we're just say to get you uh get you
padded down real quick all right just
make sure you don't have any guns you
don't have any guns on you do you no
okay all right we're going to quick do
that okay and then we're to get you
right on out of those okay it's just for
our safety all right and you weren't
putting keeping your hands on top of
your head for us
okay how old are you
bud how old are you bud 11 all right
perfect no nothing on yet we're going to
take those righted on off all
right did any one of the other kids have
guns on them earlier just came from with
football game
okay he's 17 this a problem yeah he's 17
and he's kicking our windows out do you
understand what's kind of going on bud
okay we just had someone called and said
that a a black male about 13 had a gun
in his hand walking with a black male
about uh with a black shirt okay right
in this area all right we didn't say it
was you okay but we had you you match
the description with the red shirt okay
and we just have to make sure that
everything's okay if there had been a
gun or anything like that all right so
didn't want to upset you or anything
like that we just just for our safety
for your safety as well all right um
where are you guys heading to today we
was going to Little Caesars Little
Caesars okay did you guys just come back
from Little Caesars no we was walking to
Little Caesar okay gotcha all right
where were you guys coming from
was coming from home okay all right um
do you have your phone number for your
for your
mom all three of you guys no okay just
the one in the white shirt the one in
the white shirt white shirt who's the
who's the kid in the black to you he's
my sister my sister boyfriend okay is he
the one taking care of you guys right
now cuz he said your guys' parents were
out of
town him him no he told us that your
guys' parents were out of town let's get
off to the side a little bit on the
sidewalk I don't want you on on the
street right on over here bud you're not
in any trouble you understand that right
do you understand what was kind of going
on on there yeah all right we didn't
want to upset you or anything like that
all right main thing is just make sure
that you guys are safe everyone else is
safe and that we're safe okay all right
do you have any questions for us no I
know it's kind of a scary situation but
we want to just make sure that you you
guys are okay as well all
right all
right did you see any kids walking
around here that that had a gun okay all
right right there right
here what's your granddad's
name all right we'll talk to him real
quick